lock him to this video part 15 I've
always lead all mostly to look it up so
many so many parts part 15 of them world
championship appetizing serious and here
we have a game of the world champion
again and it's um we start aren't
against Pune my of Muslim Paula Myo the
form of freedom world champion won this
knockout tournament if i remember
correctly 2002 um at the time the game
was played 2006 fulham I avanza was a
rounded top around top 10 even though
maybe even slightly slightly higher it's
hard to keep those ratings into
perspective to 740 hear dat the time as
mentioned played in 2006's Sofia a metal
masters let's see what happens I'm
playing evil as usual and we get a crack
on put my of play some many opening so
we cannot really say that this is a
special special line or something um
yeah something is a huge expert on he
plays many lines yeah Allen tone usually
goes for them straight forward Knight c3
or Knight d2 to get to the classical
line year of the caro-kann he also plays
the advance from time to time but this
is the usual choice however in light of
the upcoming World Championship match
them Carol card is probably am not too
likely opening two to emerge you never
know what month is going to play with
the connoisseur not one of his usual
openings okay we have the classical
variation with Bishop f5 and
right place this line the absolute main
line and probably the most promising
line not that it leads to much with the
alternatives are normally even less
threatening so we get to get to this
position so what term has right
accomplished with the D H pawn push yeah
it gains a bit of space on the King side
and allows on various ideas one
important issue is this confirmation
here quite often is rather favorable for
white in the end game and we've seen
some of this Layton this this game as
well on another issue however is that
this poem on h5 can get weak in the
middle game if you imagine a knight on
f6 attacking the pawn and if like
manages to get rid of the g3 night you
can sometimes even win the pot so the
kingside situation is as interesting
white also sometimes gets the idea to
use the rook on the edge farm like rook
edge form alright in six Bishop f4 yeah
Bishop f4 is more active way to play
than Bishop d2 there are many am um yeah
subtle nuances here Bishop d2s as
mentioned the other move after Bishop f4
were done on plate black can also go for
a queen a5 check or Bishop before check
both trying to provoke the Moose III by
the pond my of just develops which is
also possible of course long castle
Bishop e7 and 94 yeah 94 is played
mostly to free up the Jeep on if black
castles short which seems to be a his
plan and the G porn is the battering ram
to hope
up to G file the night is also not doing
much on g3 so 94 so a normal way to
proceed and the Apollo miles takes the
chance to to simplify the position too
corny for Knight f6 with tempo you have
the Queen basically a only has d 30 e2
and that's not much of a difference the
interesting point is this moves Queen d5
this attacks the airport it also attacks
the h-bomb though so what I mentioned
sometimes actually happens that black
can attack the h5 phone and ok what is
why it's supposed to do you need to
attend to those ideas we played see form
and now black played Queenie form which
basically forces the Queen trade yeah
opponent takes it drops back to e3 yeah
this is in fact a very common position
on rising from this opening and turn at
the time the probably most promising way
for black to play was not really
appreciated correctly I'm not sure if
someone played it at the time but it
wasn't really am the most popular booth
nowadays black is mostly playing the f5
here which at first glance looks a bit
weird at least in my book but and this
is not what pull my of play time just
trying to explain how this position
nowadays is handled and f5 is really
interesting concept one idea is that it
it covers the GG foursquare so white
cannot easily expand with G form
sometimes you even can use this attack
against h5 is mentioned and yeah why is
this move
yeah somewhat weird you ready move the f
porn in this kind of structure where it
looks like there can be something
happening on the file this backward porn
is X but in fact and how it's about ever
going to get some pressure against the
pond it's a long time from yeah
achieving something on the file and you
can also not easily expel this night for
me for um yeah white in fact quite often
placed 92 in this position and then
exchange of nights is quite helpful for
black so on this seems to be the most
promising way to play but am i if I ever
just cancelled which at the time was the
Normans no 95 here 95 is of course the
natural enough myth centralizing the
night and now in case of any ass porn
moves there's also 96 as a possible
imply this should be six he played and
now f3 yeah and the next move was
probably questionable and nevertheless
it is very difficult in this game to
exactly pinpoint the the losing moves or
something like the decisive mistake by
black he is just slowly slowly pushed
back okay three I think probably he
should just return to have six and
continue to try to simplify like Luke
the eighth and maybe even consider to
take at the right moment you played the
night here this I think it loses time
the night is not especially well placed
I've looked yeah Angie form and now the
night only has got the seven square this
is not exactly brilliant
the night is controlling and nothing no
squirrel some really am not doing much
only seven I mean an f6 it's also not
doing so much but at least them you can
can maneuver from f6 I hear you can go
to c8 at what it is doing yeah black is
slightly cramped you see that this early
f5 idea would have prevented this kind
of expansion on the kingside 93 this is
very typical and important move that can
easily be yeah underestimated black is
not really I guess not really trying on
threatening to take only five but just
putting this on d3 controlling vital
squares especially five and c5 is simply
a good idea to to keep maximum pressure
on black it prevents c5 it prevents me
five and if black is not going to play
any of those moves then he will be m
yahoo s forever basically suffering from
the lack of space and it simply prevents
any exchanges retreating the night so
this is a good move and something to
remember yeah be five spot upon my
effetti wants to to somehow open up the
position and try to maybe relieve some
of the pressure by trading on the B file
okay of course here white plays be three
you shouldn't even consider c5 because
it gives away this fantastic square
so just me three it's no problem at all
the only thing you need to watch out for
us of course that the sea porn is not
going to be weak something like this
would put pressure on the porn but we'd
see that black is not going to manage
that played Bishop c7 first yeah then
the rock isn't doing much on age 3 it
should be retreated to age 12 to be
connected and be ready to be used
differently Bishop b6 and yeah this is
an interesting point again how should
white continue here the key moves yes
night to see 5 and this a move that can
easily be a birria assess incorrectly
simply because of the fact that it can
easily happen that doubled pawns on the
C file emerged we see her that in the
game for a while your first play rook to
e8 and our King c2 and now we see what
would I just described took him and he
took on c5 and this is the type of
position you needed to evaluate
correctly after before putting the night
on c5 and it turns out if you look at
this in more detail or with a little bit
of time spent to appreciate the details
that this position is in fact very nice
for white yeah why is that it's all
about 11 piece and it's the night only
seven yeah please check what squares
have might we might go to this is all
Cabot d5 is covered
now this note how useful the c-4 point
is being part of the double pot just
excellent de placed and well the night
can go to see eight but as you see this
is also a road to nowhere so what is
this night ever going to do in this game
and it turns out not much it's a very
difficult now for black to to even keep
the game going you played me five yeah
now the second very important point look
t6 those points are really great they
control lightly squares and they provide
this this entry squares like d6 and yeah
like it's never able to take 1d6 just
for instance if you would take now
there's an instant win of a piece and
this means that black is completely tied
down if you move to the night then c6 is
gone like this guy entered service its
winning we night CA deserve it's not
much much use useful anyway because
where's this not going to go but then
yeah this this shows that like is in
really deep trouble he tries on to
activate the rukon the B file but at the
end why it is just more active instead
of work to you one which is good the
author could have played rupees happen
also very strong move attacking here and
keeping the night under pressure but
rock t1 is is good and now d8 exchanging
11 payoff rooks this is some check
useful and
he keeps poking around in blacks
position it's still the problem this
night is never going to move it doesn't
have any squares okay keeps the fball I
know Bishop 31 if at this moment you see
the idea at the end then would be very
good maybe you can try to figure out
what the bishop is doing on you want
yeah in fact the ideas that the bishop
1f to let me just briefly put it back
it's um it's not doing so much at the
moment it covers the c5 pond but this
pawn is never going to be attacked and
yeah white is trying to activate the
special and ideas like that entirely
possible no so very nicely activating
the bishop yay played look to yourself
maybe you get this in nope just keeping
all counterplay I'm down John ig8 the
only square available now a forum this
is just a very strong play the idea of a
force to play a-five a-six rock PA tande
rupee 7 and resides basically this is
the way to make progress here the
problem of this position for white is
that it's all very nice he's got a
commanding um position where black
cannot really move much especially
notice night but how exactly do you do
you win it's simple it's simply the fact
that you don't have any porn breaks
available you cannot busy move any bond
so this April pushes the way forward and
dumb black gets completely helpless
against that he played g6 not just a
five white also could have could have
taken here check but this is no
particular progress he wants to keep the
position as is here not to allow any
possible transformation that might
activate the the night this is just very
straightforward yeah here we go as
mentioned rugby 7s the plan and this is
very hard to work to to combat also note
that black was somehow you're almost
forced to play the G porn and if you
will remember what I said on move from
7-8 this push of the edge porn at the
end has created a weakness on h6 as the
Jeep ones have been exchanged look at
this now I know maybe you say that okay
you can tell whatever you want after the
game it just happened here but this is
nothing that happens regularly in this
opening now if you have studied some
games and the classical caro-kann you
will see that it happens really often
that this port side this King side
formation is quite often leading to this
kind of weakness on on on h6 we are king
f7 black really cannot do much still
never going to move the night to
somewhere somebody useful and okay you
could could have thought about that but
what I do now still how is white going
to win Bishop a 5 mm hmm
not quite sure what is the idea of
bishop 85 95 plate trying to activate
the night and here you can can have a
look for yourself try to win them or try
to find the decisive web stew to
strengthen White's position this was
already planned when Allen played Bishop
you won him yep the designs of movers
Bishop to b6 which is very nice yeah
just a desperado Bishop that with root
b7 connection with that we win the SF on
down black simply has no defense IAM
Jackie gave this check now what is just
winning the porn and like I never take
it takes white simply recaptures and
then those bones will promote King at
five and just taking taking the pawns
off check yeah at the end the bishop has
won the porn gay porn and check those
pawns are simply too far advanced check
check ya know the seaborne also gains
momentum check captain TM put my of
resigned so very straightforward win for
this year it's not the kind of game that
lets you open the champagne bottles but
it's very instructive in in many ways it
starts
93 which simply keeps the pressure on
honor maximum level not allowing any
simplifying exchanges next very
important moment is this move that
allowed this the some poor structure
transition with this doubled pawns which
this serves in the specific position who
are just to strength not a weakness have
also note that black has a hard time not
to take as if he would not take let's
say he a him he took end provoked this
double pants if he um if he wouldn't do
that immediately whiter some ways to
this was bad just hit the wrong button
I'm sorry White has the additional idea
to play a four a five or a forehead
capture the some would have probably
forced this capture anyway so this is
not really a mistake here what upon my
plate however the position after that I
think is almost not defensible I'm not
one hundred percent sure um what what
his big mistake was so very difficult
the same I mean I'm pretty sure that
instead of this so in general instead of
this castles that f5 is better okay and
that this is not such a great idea to
provoke those moves was g four and so on
to at the end put the night on his
heaven as we saw this is just an unlucky
square I mean he he never got anywhere
with this night just imagine it would be
on f6 then you have rupee a tonight
aged 72 fa to d7 and so on we have some
yeah at least some maneuvering room from
his heaven it's just just basically a
dead piece and yeah we saw that in this
configuration here with a double bond
this piece is it's just doomed to a
passive position and then very very nice
to play to solve this route g6 taking
control and then very nicely can hear
this this idea to activate the bishop
and the a pawn push this is just getting
the maximum out of such a position using
all forces you can only win usually if
you use all your forces and this is the
a porn the end the bishop and this at
the end one da pawn and the game so very
instructive strategical win here by
Anand uh not really is some quite a
universal player you have all kinds of
games of you know Pettis his um his
games and there there are many f could
almost what 3,000 games on database
you'll find it all the tacking games the
defensive games the purely positional
grinds there's there's everything in
them and this is one of them um yeah not
not to complicate it but still very
instructive positional games I hope
you've enjoyed it and I'll be back
tomorrow again with a Carson game thanks
for watching